hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast contamination control in
the hydraulic industry presented by rob
fish we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by beckman coulter
life sciences beckman coulter develops
manufactures and markets products that
simplify automate and innovate complex
biomedical testing more than 275,000
baton culture systems operate in both
diagnostics and life sciences laboratory
on seven continents for over 75 years
our products have been making a
difference in people's lives by
improving the productivity of medical
professionals and scientists supplying
critical information for improving
patient health and delivering prostitute
solutions for research and discovery to
learn more about Bethenny culture life
sciences please visit www dr oracle
every channel dear moderator for today's
event this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the cee button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credits before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive and we encourage
you to participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green two and a button located in
the lower left of the presentation
window and type your question into the
box that appears on the screen well
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation also
please notice that you will be viewing
the trees entation in the slide window
to enlarge the window just click on the
screen icon located on the lower right
and finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of the presentation window or you can
use the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem thank you now
I'd like to introduce Rob fish the owner
and lead instructor of basic hydraulics
com Rob develops and conducts training
that extends the life of hydraulic
component reduces hydraulic related
downtime and improves the productivity
of hydrology
equipment it has a wide range of
experience designing and troubleshooting
hydraulic circuitry Rob burned the fluid
power society's fluid power specialist
certification in 1987 a circuit design
work has been featured in hydraulics and
maddox magazine Ron's education training
and hands-on experience allow them to
provide hydraulic related training that
is interesting understandable relevant
and useful please join me in welcoming
Rob fish I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello everyone
and thank you for attending I've been
teaching basic hydraulic classes for a
long time now and every time I teach a
class i'm reminded of a story that Zig
Ziglar taught once at a seminar I
attended he said that every year
millions and millions of people go over
to their hardware stair store and buy
something they don't want they buy a
drill and they really don't want drills
what they want are holes they just have
to buy the drill in order to be able to
get the holes and I think that when it
comes to a contamination control webinar
we're talking about the same sort of
thing what we're here for is not so much
contamination control as the benefits
that we get from contamination control
years ago I taught a basic hydraulics
class for a company in Decatur Illinois
and during the class they mentioned that
they were having some problems with the
show go valves that one servo valve was
breaking down about every six to eight
weeks and they couldn't find a reliable
repair shop so instead of repairing them
they'd come into the habit of replacing
their server valves they were averaging
about seven breakdowns a year and it was
costing them between the cost of servo
valves and downtime over thirty six
thousand dollars a year now as we'll
talk about a little bit later on all
hydraulic components are sensitive to
contamination and in fact the number one
cause of hydraulic component failure is
contamination and servo valves are more
sensitive to contamination than many
other types of hydraulic components
fact if contamination was an allergy
suffered by hydraulic components servo
valves would be suffering from that
severe peanut allergy they are extremely
sensitive to continue after the class
the people in the class convinced the
company their company to spend a bit
over three thousand dollars to control
the contamination reaching the servo
valve now I haven't talked to these
folks in quite a while but the last time
I talked with them they gone three years
without the servo valve failing for that
three year period that worked out to be
a saving of a hundred and five thousand
dollars so they invested three grand and
they saved over a hundred and five
thousand dollars they controlled the
camp contamination but the result was a
huge cost savings during today's webinar
we're going to do a basic non-technical
look at what contamination does
hydraulics the idea is that we want to
extend the component life we want to
reduce downtime the bottom line from
extending the component life and
reducing a downtime is that we are going
to have company save money increase
their profits and hopefully save some
jobs because they're profitable and can
afford to employ more people in the next
40 minutes or so we're going to go over
what hydraulics is how hydraulics work
would talk some about particle sizes
we'll go over some of the basics of
contamination there's a rule of thumb
for filtration that we used to use years
ago the good old days we'll talk about
that and what curtain accepted practices
are from contamination and also we'll
talk a little bit about how clean is
clean enough and how you achieve that
level we'll finish up with a few minutes
of questions and answers and then we're
out of there to start with just to make
sure that I understand how much to go
off script can we do a quick poll now
down I'd like to have the poll put up
and please let me know how familiar you
are with hydraulics
okay thank you very much so let's start
we're talking a little bit about what
hydraulics is a textbook definition of
it might be a way to transmit power by
pushing on the confined fluid and I'll
use a log splitter to explain how this
works we're going to start with a power
ours going to come in from the gasoline
engine and with hydraulics we're going
to transmit that power over to a log and
use the power to split the log when we
turn on the gasoline engine the shaft of
the gasoline engine is going to start to
rotate as the engine shaft turns that in
turn is going to turn the shaft on the
pump we're transmitting the power from
the gasoline engine to the pump as the
pump turns hydraulic fluid is pushed
from the reservoir into the pump and
then the pump is going to push the fluid
up to a control valve at control valve
controls the direction of the cylinder
that we're operating so we're going to
call it a directional control valve and
that directional control valve has got
three positions in one position the
fluid goes into the directional control
valve turns around goes out that blue
line at the bottom goes back to a filter
which is going to hopefully take out
some of the contamination through the
filter and back into tank the fluid is
making a loop from the reservoir to the
pump to the valve through the filter and
back to tank now we're going to go ahead
and remove the log from the drawing just
so that you can see the cylinder a
little bit better and I'm going to shift
the valve I'm going to shove that handle
forward towards the cylinder it parts
inside that directional control valve
are going to shift instantaneously we're
going to have fluid go from the
directional control valve into the back
end of the cylinder some people call
that the base end or the cap end we'll
call it the back end for now as fluid
enters the back end of the cylinder it's
going to push the cylinder rod out and
as the cylinder rod comes out any fluid
that happens to be in the rod
end it's going to go out the rod end
port shown there and blue now and go
back to the directional control valve
and from the directional control valve
it's going to head back through the
return line through the filter and back
out to tank we shift the valve again
into the center position fluid once
again goes from the pump to the
directional control valve here the
return line filter and back to tank we
shift the valve again and pull the
handle back and now the pressurized
fluid is going to go into the rod head
and as the fluid goes into the rot in
the cylinder is going to retract as the
cylinder retracts any fluid that happens
to be in the back end of the cylinder is
going to go through the directional
control valve through the return line
back to the filter and find it back to
take now if you had x-ray vision which
some people think would probably be a
pretty nice thing to have you would see
that when the cylinder is retracted the
oil level in the reservoir is up near
the top and when the cylinder extends
the oil level in the reservoir drops
down to the bottom we'll take a look at
how a hydraulic cylinder works to see
why that happens now I see that there
are some people attending today who have
no experience with hydraulics so let me
simplify this a hydraulic cylinder is
much like those old push-up pops that we
used to have with a push up pop if you
push on the stick the ice cream comes
out the top if you turn the push up pop
over and you push on the ice cream then
the stick is going to move out and
that's the exact same thing that happens
with a hydraulic cylinder when we push
on the bottom the stick comes out so if
we compare the two a cylinder and a push
up pop have a lot in common the
cylinders got a tube on the filler I'm
sorry the push up pop has a tube and on
the cylinder we call it a body there's a
little platform on the push up pop it
holds the ice cream and the cylinder
will call that the piston the stick on
the push up pop is pretty much the same
as
pissed in on the hydraulic cylinder so
if we put the whole thing together and
turn on our x-ray vision we can see that
we've got the body containing the piston
and the rod things would get a little
bit messy if we just threw all against
the bottom of the cylinder so we're
going to put on end caps will put an end
cap on the bottom and then then to cap
on the top with a couple of ports and
then we'll connect some plumbing turning
on our x-ray vision again you can see
the piston inside the ride inside and
now if we put fluid into the bottom end
of the cylinder that fluid is going to
enter the cylinder and it's going to
push against the piston as the fluid
pushes against the piston the piston is
going to move forward and any fluid
that's on the rod side of the cylinder
is going to get pushed out of the rod
end port and go back to our directional
control valve and as this happens our
cylinder extends when the cylinder is
extended completely I'm sorry as the
cylinder extends any fluid in the piston
end is going to go out and is going to
go to the valve when our cylinder has
completely extended we can push fluid
into the top end port the rod in port
and that fluid will push on the piston
and cause the cylinder to retract and as
the cylinder retracts any fluid on the
piston end is going to go back through
the directional control valve and back
to tank as the cylinder retracts when
the cylinder is completely extended
there's nothing in the bottom end of the
cylinder so the fluid can completely
fill that area and in this particular
case it will hold about three gallons of
oil when the cylinder retracts the pits
the rod takes up some of the space and
with that rod occupying some of the
space we can't put as much oil in the
rod end as we can input any other end
it's got a pretty good sized rod and
this particular cylinder will hold about
two gallons of oil on the rod end means
if we put two gallons into the rod end
three gallons are going to get pushed
out and if we put three
challenge a fluid into the back end then
two gallons are going to come out of the
piston end and that's going to change
the fluid level now somewhere out there
someone is probably thinking what the
heck does this have to do with
contamination control if we go back to
our log splitter let's see if that on
the top of the reservoir there's a
little breather and that allows air to
go in and out of the reservoir as the
cylinder extends and retracts when the
fluid level rises fluid is pushed out of
the breather and goes out into the
nearby atmosphere when the fluid level
drops that space that is created by the
fluid level dropping we have air from
the nearby area go pushing through the
breather and fill up that space now as
the air is coming into the reservoir any
airborne contamination in the area as
the opportunity to come in and go into
the reservoir we end up with the
possibility of having contamination
inside the reservoir now if you look
around most machines you really don't
see any contamination orly in the air
but back in 2008 hydraulics pneumatics
published an article that says
essentially we don't want any particles
larger than 10 microns inside our
hydraulic fluid we measure contamination
and hydraulics and microbes remember
that servo valve that I mentioned before
they were having servo valves fail until
they put on a dream micron filter in the
pilot line so when we eliminated the 3
micron particles the servo valve
continued to work so we've got
hydraulics and pneumatics saying for
most hydraulic systems nothing bigger
than 10 microns for servo valves nothing
bigger than 3 microns and unfortunately
the breeder used on many hydraulic
systems as a 40 micron filter that means
that that element that is filtering the
air going in and out of our reservoir
can lot particle
as big as 40 micron and reservoir and
the breeders have got a little bypass
built into them so that if the breather
element gets clogged instead of
filtering the air all of the air goes in
so particles bigger than 40 micron can
enter the reservoir I don't know about
you but when I first started working
with hydraulics I had absolutely no clue
what 40 micron 10 micron rich micron
particles work so let me give you some
sizes for perspective if you pretend
that that purple dot is a grain of salt
it would be about a hundred micron that
little backwards you on the end of the
one hundreds of the abbreviation for
micron I don't have many of them left
but when I had them my hair was about 70
micron in diameter young folks can see
things as small as 40 microns those of
us a little bit older need cheaters to
see things that small a white blood cell
is approximately 25 micron in diameter
let me repeat that a white blood cell is
approximately 25 micron in diameter it
means that hydraulics pneumatics and
everybody else is saying that we don't
want things in our oil as large as a
white blood cell do not try this please
however if you were to cut yourself and
bleed into the hydraulic reservoir your
white blood cells are big enough to void
the warranty on most hydraulic pumps
motors and valves and if it was a piece
of metal the size of a white blood cell
it could cause the hydraulic components
to fail red blood cells are eight micron
so eight micron is kind of okay to go
floating through hydraulic fluid but
it's too big to go through the servo
valve
and when we talk about the number of
components if you were to try using your
blood as a hydraulic fluid there are so
many white blood cells and so many red
blood cells inside our blood that there
are too many pieces of contamination to
run through a hydraulic component so why
do we care about airborne contamination
because as the cylinder extends and the
fluid level drops any air contamination
in the air that happens to go through
the breather is going to go down into
the reservoir and mix in with the fluid
as our pump runs hydraulic fluid is
going to be drawn into the pump any
contamination that's in the fluid is
going to run through the pump possibly
damaging the pump at fluids guy come out
of the pump and go into our directional
control valve once again possibly
damaging the directional control valve
then go out of the directional control
valve into the cylinder and as the
cylinder extends any fluid in the rod
into the cylinder is going to go back in
through the directional control valve
and then our fluid containing
contamination is going to go through the
return line and get to the filter
unfortunately filters are not a hundred
percent effective at removing
contamination return line filters they
might be eighty or ninety percent
efficient cheap return line filters
might only be fifty or sixty percent
efficient and when a filter gets dirty
it will go into bypass mode and when the
filter is in bypass mode all of the
dirty fluid goes through the filter and
it filters zero percent efficient so we
can count on at least some contamination
going through the filter going through
the return line and back into tank and
then as the hydraulic system continues
to run it can go through the pump again
so contamination in a hydraulic system
might cycle through the system many
times if we're being trapped by the
consulter
now if you would please do me a favor
hover your hands just a wee bit over
your desk or the table beside you don't
touch it just a wee bit over the desk
now move your hand back and forth left
to right and you're not touching the
desk and there's absolutely no friction
and thanks you can stop doing that that
is how many hydraulic components operate
the moving parts inside pumps motors and
valves they don't actually touch each
other there's a thin film of hydraulic
fluid that separates the different
components so as parts inside our
different components move that hydraulic
film this layer provides a thin layer of
lubrication it provides a seal to keep
things from moving out it moves heat
away from the moving parts and it
carries contamination way don't do this
but if you were to put your hand over
your desk and pour some oil down you
could now put your hand on the desk and
rub it back and forth and your hand
would be separated from the desk by that
thin layer of oil and ideally we would
suggest that your hand would move a
little bit easier than it would if there
was no oil there now if we use a really
thick oil we could put some
contamination there in this case let's
say we put a piece of sandpaper down we
put that oil on top of the sand paper
you could rub your hand back and forth
over the sandpaper and it wouldn't do
much damage it would still do some
damage it just wouldn't do a heck of a
lot so if we have a good quality
lubrication we can handle a little bit
of contamination now do me a favor and
put your hand back on your desk and this
time press down as hard as you can just
with your hand and as you're pressing
down you're probably straining a little
bit and how far how hard do you think
you're pressing down thanks very much
appreciate that when I press down I can
generate about 30 pounds of force so
pressing down we generate somewhere
around 30 pounds of course if you're
stronger
you might make 40 if you're a little bit
less bulky than me you might make 20
when I put my hand in contact with the
desk the area that's touching the desk
has an area of about fifteen square
inches so if I do a little bit of math
I've got 30 pounds of force that I'm
pressing down with and I'm dividing that
over 15 square inches that comes out to
that to psi I've got two pounds per
square inch that I'm pushing down with
and I'm generating about 30 pounds of
force and my guess is that you're
probably going to generate about the
same amount let's go back to the log
splitter at log splitter can generate
over 1600 psi and 20,000 pounds of force
other hydraulic equipment like the press
that the servo valve is on can generate
over 5,000 psi going back to the log
splitter that 1600 psi is 800 times as
much pressure as we generated while
pushing on the desk and the question
that I've got is can you imagine what
would happen if you had a piece of
contamination on your hand that was
pressed with 1600 psi now when we look
at basic hydraulics we're going to say
that pressure and a confined fluid acts
equally in all directions Pascal's law
and anytime you take a basic hydraulics
class we're going to teach you that if
we pretend that this device you're
looking at is a hydraulic component it's
got a pipe coming in from the left and a
pipe going out to the right we're going
to put flow in from the left and we're
going to have flow go out to the right
now let's put a little piece of
contamination going into the piping as
look at that turn the pipe sideways you
can see that the contamination is
completely surrounded by the fluid so
that means that because the fluid is all
the way around the particle that 1600
psi is not slamming the particle against
the piping it's just kind of carrying it
along and we
the same pressure on all sides and most
hydraulic components we've got a
passageway and then we've got a very
narrow opening and maybe a small orifice
the narrow openings in the orifice can
allow for lubrication they can lead to
the flow they can provide a dream path
into all kinds of things that are vital
to the operation of hydraulic circuit
going back to our piece of contamination
we can see that it's entering the pipe
and as you've probably guessed it's
going to tumble and it's going to turn
and it reaches that orifice it's going
to block it completely and with the
orifice being blocked by the
contamination there's no way that any
flow can get through the orifice and if
we're operating at low pressure maybe a
hundred psi 200 psi 500 psi that
pressure is just going to hold the
particle there and it's not going to do
much damage and at low pressures if we
reverse the flow or we turn off our
system that contamination might just
drop down to the port drop down inside
and then maybe next time we start up it
will get carried through the orifice
with loot without doing any damage but
if we're operating at high pressure when
that little piece of contamination hits
that orifice it's like when we were
talking about pushing that piece of
contamination in your hand at 1600 psi
that contamination is going to get
driven into the orifice it's going to
block the orifice it may damage the
orifice and when we turn off the system
it's not going to break out we're going
to have total catastrophic failure of
the component and it's going to need to
be repaired or replaced now in addition
to catastrophic failure there's two
other kinds of damage that can be caused
by contamination we've got a bunch of
small particles moving over and against
things it can act like sandpaper and we
rode the internal parts pretend for a
moment that this is the stationary part
of a hydraulic pony and we're really
going to magnify it a lot we're going to
put a moving part above and thin film of
hydraulic
good at that thin film of hydraulic
fluid is actually only microns in height
it's smaller than a red blood cell and
because this is a contamination webinar
we're going to put some contamination
enter and if the contamination moves
through there it's going to gradually
where the parts kind of like if we were
running sandpaper through there and as
it wears the parts the opening between
the parts is going to increase and that
larger space is going to allow more
hydraulic fluid to flow between the
parts so if the part used to leak 10
cubic inches a minute before it might
have leaked 15 or 20 cubic inches more
because there's a bigger space for the
forget to go to so why is this matter if
we get more leakage well the speed of
hydraulic motor and hydraulic cylinder
is determined by the amount of fluid
that flows through them going back to
our log splitter let's say that our pump
is putting out 10 gallons per minute
which we abbreviate as gpn and it takes
10 seconds for the cylinder to extend if
we reduce the amount of flow to say five
gallons per minute cutting the flow in
half is going to double the amount of
time that it takes so instead of taking
10 seconds to extend its going to take
20 seconds to extend so as internal
parts where our equipments going to run
slower in addition as we week internally
we're going to generate heat and when we
heat up fluid it gets thinner and when
it gets thinner it doesn't do as good a
job of lubricating and protecting as
thick fluid does and as a result the
thinner fluid is going to increase the
chance of our components being damaged
by contamination the other type of issue
caused by particles is something i could
call scratch and dent or more accurately
scratching chip once again we've got a
very girly greatly magnified piece of
hydraulic componentry we're going to
have fluid come in from the bottom it's
to go through the component and it's
going to go out to the right we've got
some very very small areas between the
moving parts that are filled with ill
then the film of hydraulic fluid that
will carry a way that he and provides
your protection from contamination we
aren't going to get any flow through
that because it's so dog actually that's
not correct we're going to get cubic
inches a minute or four going through
because they're so narrow now the sizes
of these openings as I said are greatly
exaggerated and all the parts are
separated by a thin down before now if
we move apart to the right we're going
to block off the port and now flow comes
up to that movable part and then it
stops and if we move it back the other
way then we get flow through there now
we start to move again and this time a
chunk of contamination is going to get
trapped between the movable part and the
stationary part in this case the term
chunk is totally subjective the chunk
might be a medical medical the metal
particle 20 micron long 12 micron high
and ate my crime why just picking
presented here but it's smaller than a
white blood cell moving parts going to
share that chunk and make it break into
a whole bunch of smaller parts it's also
going to chip off the edges of the
moving part and the stationary part in
addition it's going to scratch where it
goes through the moving part and what
happens with all of that is we create
more contamination and we create a
pathway for fluid to leak by so now
instead of feeling completely when we
close the valve or close whatever it is
we end up having some leakage going
through where before we might have had
60 gallons per minute going out to our
system now maybe a gallon or two is
going to leak and go back to internal
leakage and not being able to use for
our system and what does this matter
well let me
tell you about Joe's woes picture there
you see a Sam the owner of continental
construction contractors actually that's
not true this is clipart and that's not
really his name I changed the names and
you'll see why here in a moment a few
years back Sam bought a new excavator
and some trucks to use on the job that
he won and with what he charged for his
hourly rate he made forty dollars an
hour profit on each and every one of
those trucks as they operated for a job
that he did for 60 days in the course of
the 60 days he ended up making over
76,000 dollars in profit he determined
during that job that his excavator
averaged filling his dump trucks three
times an hour now Sam's company been
busy and they haven't done a really good
job of maintaining your equipment back
when everything is new is pumps put 60
gallons per minute into this system
contamination caused by stuff coming in
and contamination coming in through the
breather cap contamination that was
ingested as we ought system operated it
wore the pump down and now instead of
putting out 60 gallons per minute he
gets only 51 gallons permitted abusable
fluid to do the work the excavator has
slowed down but the change happened so
slowly that nobody really noticed it the
last August Sam's company want to bid
for virtually an identical job to the
one they did four years ago and because
it was so close Sam sharpen his pencil
and decided that he would cut his costs
a little bit cut his price is a little
bit and he based his bid on doing the
exact same work that he did four years
ago unfortunately because the excavator
was operating slower it took 60 90
minutes to fill three dump tracks
instead of 60 minutes then extra nine
minutes cut into his profits and the
bottom line is that instead of making
seventy six thousand dollars like he did
for the first job
he made only twenty-three thousand
dollars a loss of I did the math wrong
wrong that's something like fifty
thousand dollars so he didn't make any
where near as much money as he thought
he was going to make because of the
contamination slowing down his machine
and now we come to Jones woes this is
Joe Joe was the excavator operator and
when they didn't make as much money done
this job as they made before Sam fired
him because he thought Joe was doing a
terrible job and Joe wasn't doing a
terrible job as just that the
contamination caused pump to slow down
which caused big excavator to slow down
and he just couldn't work the machine is
prob quickly as possible bottom line
contamination is the number one cause of
hydraulic component failure most damage
done to components is done by particles
way too small to see so where does it
come from some of the contamination gets
built into the machine the person making
the machine he's cutting the pipes for
the log splitter and he cleaned them out
by blowing compressed air to them look
through the pipes didn't see any
contamination phipps this is clean once
again contamination that can damage
components can be as small as a white
blood cell the person welding the
reservoir did the same sort of thing is
the pipe better it did the welding it
cooked inside there no contamination
someone may have used a grinding wheel
near the log splitter when it is being
assembled some contamination comes in
when the machines operate every time
your cylinder extends and retracts you
have the possibility of debris debris
falling on the cylinder and getting
pulled back into the system a big one is
that new hydraulic fluid is not clean
enough to use in a hydraulic system it
needs to be cleaned before it can be
used and the fluid is poured into the
reservoir instead of being pumped into a
dedicated port opening the port to pour
it in can ingest contamination into the
system do
maintenance if you open up any ports
that's an open invitation for
contamination that we can't see to enter
the system and I know that it doesn't
happen with anybody here but there are
places where maintenance people don't
use plastic plugs caps on ports and
fittings in the old days we just used to
say that our Google Earth from was to
use a 10 micron filter on pumps and
motors and a 3 micron filter on servo
valves I'd like to introduce you to my
friend Kim this is a way Tim looked five
years ago he's running for his high
school track that year five years ago is
Aunt Alice mailed in a size medium
sweater for Christmas beautiful thing
and Aunt Alice has been mailing Tim a
medium-sized Christmas sweater every
year since well when Tim got to ecology
started working out and this is tim
today since changed but aunt alice is
still sending him that medium size
sweater it doesn't fit anymore like Tim
hydraulics have changed the rule of
thumb in the old days might still work
in some cases but I draw components are
not made to tighter tolerances smaller
clearances and they operate at higher
pressures in the old days piece of
contamination that would go through a
component without causing much damage
now gouges scrapes and breaks as the
food goes through the tighter clearances
so when you want to figure out how clean
your fluid d needs to be ideally you
would consult the manufacturers
literature and determine what they
require for the level of contamination
cleanliness and set a target based on
the manufacturers recommendation the
international standards organizations
created a chart that helps us describe
how much contamination there is you
through it a lot of different people use
it to specify cleanliness levels levels
for warranty cuddlings levels of what
your fluid is when you have it tested
and the chart with something like this
we're going to measure the number of
particles in a milliliter with a piece
of testing device and a milliliter is
equivalent of about a quarter of a
teaspoon of fluid or if you've got an
eyedropper about 20 drops from nine
dropper and we're going to chart three
different sizes of particles we're going
to keep track of how many particles we
have that are larger than 4 micron but
smaller than 6 micron we're going to
keep track of how many particles are
larger than 6 micron and smaller than 14
block gone and we're going to keep track
of how many particles are larger than 14
micro
so we might look at a number like I so
14 12 10 and that describes a fluid the
14 says that we've got between 80 and
160 particles larger than 4 micron and
smaller than 6 the 12 in the 1412 tells
us how many particles we have between 6
and 14 micron and the 10 tells us how
many products we have bigger than 14
micron and well ideally would go to
manufacturers and you say how clean does
it need to be there are some standards
that are generally accepted persistence
with servo valves we're looking at using
a minimum of 16 14 11 which means that
we have 320 to 640 particles in the 4
micron size 80 to 100 in the 6 to 14
size and 10 to 20 that's not a lot of
particles and once again we can't see
any of these particles they're all
smaller than a white blood cell for
general hydraulic systems we might look
at the chart and say that we want is 17
15 12 and we can tell how many of each
size we have just by looking at the
chart new hydraulic fluid is often rated
at ISO 19 17 14 do you remember we said
that I pressure and servos needed to be
filtered to 16 14 11 normal operation is
a 17-15 12 and the bottom line is that
new oil is not clean enough to use in
your hydraulic system and talked about
blood a while back ago flood has more
than 4,000 white blood cells per
milliliter and five million red blood
cells per milliliter if our hydraulic
fluid has it add as many particles as
our blood does it would destroy every
single hydraulic component out there
the question is how do you determine if
your hydraulic fluid is dirty I don't
know about you but me I struggle to
maintain my weight I've got what I call
fat tails and if I don't pay attention
to my weight I gradually creep up until
the only thing I'm comfortable and is my
fat pants and it generally takes all 15
or 20 pounds to get there so if the only
way that i knew that i was getting
overweight was when my fat pants were
the only comfortable pants I'd be fat
before I got into them so what I do
instead is every morning I get on a
scale and I check out what my way gets
now the fat cats method of checking
whether your soil is dirty or not is to
look at your components and if your
components are failing if your equipment
is running slowly if your equipment
doesn't work properly when it gets hot
that means that you have got
contamination and you need to do
something about it but by the time that
happens the damage has been done the
hydraulic equipment equivalent of me
stepping on a scale each morning is to
take a fluid sample measure the
contamination and find out what the
reading is on the ISO contamination
chart if you're fortunate enough to have
a particle counter you can test in house
but there are a bunch of labs that will
test your fluid and provide results at a
reasonable place regardless of where the
testing happens it's got to happen now I
take a prescription that is in every
single day my doctor requires I come in
for a visit and a blood test every six
months when I get into the doctor's
office a nurse has me step on the scale
she takes my pulse she measures my blood
they draw my blood pressure and then
they put all of that information they
used to put in holder on the door so the
doctor can look at it before he came in
but now they put it on a computer but
the same thing happens we sit down and
we go over the results comparing what's
happening now with what happened before
and the whole idea is that we're
checking to see if anything has
changed so that we can correct it before
it gets too much of a problem and you
should do further tests on a regular
basis for the exact same reason you want
to catch the problems while they're
still easy to fix the goals of this
webinar included extending hydraulic
component life and reducing downtime as
you've probably guessed the biggest
factor in meeting those goals is to set
a good I so tunneling this level and
maintain it other things that you can do
in order to make your components class
loggers keep the operating temperatures
within the range of your components if
the food is too hot it doesn't do a good
job of protecting your system maintain
proper additive levels in your hydraulic
systems or boring pressure spikes is
excessive system pressure keep them want
around your patrolling your baseboards
we're getting close to the end here
we'll go through a few more suggestions
on ways to reach your ice on level
cleanliness set a target level either by
consulting the manufacturers literature
or usually wanted the suggested ice and
levels that we talked about earlier in
there and then webinar you need to
figure out where you are so start off by
testing your hydraulic fluid to
determine how contaminated it is and it
doesn't meet the standards that you set
you need to clean it up and we'll
replace it when you're going to put
fluid into a system any new fluid should
be filtered several times before it goes
into the system if I was king of
hydraulics you take a drum full of
hydraulic fluid and you would run it
through a filter card and put it into an
empty drum and then you would clean the
source drum and then you would run the
fluid through the helter buggy again
putting it back into the ante drum and
you'd repeat that two more times and
yeah i know that's a royal pain in the
patootie but you know i want to have to
buy a bicycle helmet and when i went and
looked at the bicycle helmets saw them
were costly dog on an expensive and i
said to the salesman do i really need
the
one of these expensive bike helmets and
as you probably guessed or he said to me
is how much is your head work if your
hydraulic down time is expensive if your
hydraulic components are expensive you
need to take the time and filter the
fluid before you put it into the system
and if I was king of hydraulics the only
way that you could get oil into a system
would be the pump it in with a filter
card through a dedicated port it would
take oil through the filter cart and it
would go into our dedicated poor you
might also consider installing a kidney
loop system where you have a dedicated
culture that draws fluid out of the
reservoir it filters it and then it
returns it to the reservoir so those are
two things that you can do without any
problem at all these next steps consult
a full power specialist or an engineer
before making the changes because if
they're done correctly they can really
help but if you do them long they can
cause catastrophic failure destroy the
components and when you tell people rob
fish told me to do this it makes me look
bad okay first thing would be to add
high quality pressure filtration to your
system second would be to upgrade your
return line filter to a much higher
quality finer micron filter and the
third thing would be to replace any 40
micron reservoir readers with 3 micron
units once again don't do any of those
changes without consulting an engineer
because if you do them wrong it can
cause some severe problems come back to
how much can you save by doing all of
this that company in Decatur Illinois
saved nearly five thousand dollars in
three years sans excavating company safe
trip to our lost 53 thousand dollars in
just three months because they've gone
several years without filtering the
court the amount that you think is going
to depend on your exact circumstances
but generally without a doubt any money
that you spend on contamination control
pays for itself in the long run and with
that I think that were pretty much
covered all the information that we
needed to cover in
a webinar so I believe we're ready for
questions thank you rob for that
informative presentation it is time for
Q&A so if you have a question you'd like
to ask rob fish please do so now just
click on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
type your question into the box it
appears on your screen and click on the
send button will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for and how
can we like you some questions coming in
so just give us a moment here an
audience member asks which kind of fluid
is used and what are the property well
the fluid that's being used in in
hydraulics we can have a petroleum-based
bluid and we can have a synthetic base
fluid when we talk about contamination
levels most of what I've talked about
today is pretty simply used on
petroleum-based fluids the same
principles apply with synthetic fluids
it's just that the filtration
requirements are slightly different
because of the way that the synthetic
foods are designed okay and while we're
waiting for more questions to come in I
would like to once again thank Rob fish
for his presentation and ask if you have
any final comments
ruff you have any final comments you'd
like to share with the audience they are
you nope no I think that we've covered
everything the only thing that I would
suggest is when you're starting a
business they say that the key to
success is location location location
and as you've probably guessed my
feeling is that when it comes to making
money with hydraulics or having
hydraulics be a cost-effective way to do
things the key is filtration filtration
filtration thank you for that we have
another question for you how likely is
it for the hydraulic components to leak
fluid out of the hydraulic circuit and
contaminate the environment with a
well-designed system the chances are
very very slight when you get a system
that you operate with high pressure
spikes where you don't maintain it
properly then some of the hoses and
fittings can start to leak in which case
you can get leakage but generally with a
well-designed system that's operated
within its normal operating parameters
the chances are very very slight that
you'll have any fools leaking out okay
well thank you for that and I'll
continue to wrap up but many people who
have the additional questions of course
take them I would like to thank our
sponsor Bettman culture life sciences
for making today's educational webcast
possible this webinar has been approved
for continuing educational credits
please click on the cee button at the
bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits and
before we go I want to let everyone know
that today's webcast will be available
for on-demand viewing through August
twenty-eighth 2017 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting me know
when the webcast will be available for
replay we share that announcement near
their colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that is all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon why
you